and i'm always impressed when i hear
someone speak
another language whether it be english
or any language other than their native
language
hi there steve kaufman here again and
today i want to talk about english
is english difficult if it's difficult
what makes it difficult why do some
people struggle
but remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
if you follow me on a podcast service
please leave a review
now i know that many of you many of my
viewers
watch my videos to work on their english
which is a very good idea because
i try to speak clearly
the transcript of these videos uh are
all available on link to study as
lessons if you want to
so it's a good thing and if you're
interested in what i have to say which
may or may not be the case uh that's so
much the better because if you can learn
from things that are interesting of
course that's a good thing
so
i often hear people say you know i've
been studying english for
so long or my english is not good and i
don't feel confident with english i wish
i spoke english better and often the
subject comes up is english difficult
compared to i don't know russian chinese
japanese french and so forth so what's
my view on all of this
yes there are people who struggle with
english
i know people in canada immigrants who
have been there for
10 years longer and who really don't
speak english very well
so does that mean that english is
difficult i don't think so
we've all not we've all but many of us
have been watching the olympic games
and they interview athletes from
all kinds of countries
and their english is simply phenomenal
and i'm always impressed when i hear
someone speak
another language whether it be english
or any language other than their native
language
why are the and the same is true of
athletes who professional athletes who
come to north america or perhaps the
same is true those who go to england
from different countries they end up
speaking english very well
so
in fact more people learn english and
more people learn to speak english well
than any other language because more
people
need english than any other language as
an international language
so
is it difficult i think there are things
that make english difficult and there
are things that make english easy
but the biggest factor in
terms of how
successful people are at learning
english is the learner
him or herself
a the learner may make unreasonable
demands on themselves in other words you
don't have to perform you don't have to
be perfect you don't have to sound like
a native if you learn english as an
adult you'll probably always have an
accent you'll probably always have a
certain turn of phrase which reflects
your native language habits that you
simply can't
you know
get rid of and i've seen this in people
who speak english extremely well and
still have a german turn of phrase or a
swedish turn or phrase or a japanese
tournament phrase that they aren't going
to get rid of and so we needn't worry
about that
english is a popular form of
international communication and for that
reason
it's for communication so it's not like
you're taking some exalted you know
tests in japanese or chinese and you're
working on getting the pronunciation
just so and
it's not like that it's just for
communicating so once you accept that
you just have to be able to communicate
and i said many times the most important
thing is comprehension so you have to
have a good level of comprehension if
you have a good level of comprehension
the person speaking with you especially
a native speaker feels more comfortable
because they can sense if you understand
and if you don't understand
so now when we talk about tests it has
been my experience that those people who
learn english and focus on ielts and
toeic and toefl they end up speaking
less well i don't think
the olympic athletes
or the professional
hockey players from russia or slovakia
or sweden who play in north america
or maybe brazilians or argentinians who
play soccer in the uk
uh or croatians or whatever
they don't take
toefl ielts i don't think so
they learn from their teammates and
they're not shy about using whatever
they have and as they use it and as they
hear more they get better so i think
the extent to which people take these
tests it's almost
in inverse relationship to their ability
to speak the language so it's something
i would definitely advise against
focusing on these tests your results on
these tests
i had
in fact the beginning of link was when
we had we had hired a person from china
it's a long story i heard that he had
his money stolen as an immigrant
arriving at the airport we said we'd
help him out give him a job he was in
i.t he had a high score in toefl he
couldn't communicate in english quite
simply and it was to help him that we
developed link but he had a high score
in toefl and the high scores in these
tests don't mean that you speak well and
then absence of test results in these
tests of english as a second language
the fact that you haven't taken these
doesn't mean that you can't speak the
language
there are a lot of languages that i
speak well there are some that i don't
speak so well
i've never had a test of proficiency the
only one i had to test the proficiency
in was chinese because it was my job so
i took this
british foreign service exam in mandarin
chinese so tests i think are a bit of an
obstacle so that makes english a little
difficult another thing that makes
english difficult is
perhaps like many languages but english
is kind of like an amalgamation of
languages so 2 000 years ago
the romans were in britain and the
original inhabitants there spoke some
celtic language and i'm not a linguist
like luke who i had on here yes last
week talking about
uh latin and greek and this is
fascinating and so the romans were there
2000 years ago but the local inhabitants
spoke a celtic language
and surprisingly the latin or component
of english doesn't come from the romans
as i understand it it comes from the
norman french who invaded in 1066
but so these celtic people were suffered
the invasion of the anglo-saxons
and that brought a major sort of
germanic element to english
and then england was subject to
invasions from the
scandinavians and especially the east
coast
of britain had a significant
influence
from scandinavian languages and of
course in 1066 the normans who actually
were
vikings who had invaded france became
french-speaking and then invaded
britain and brought their language with
them
and the upper classes spoke french
that's why as you may know beef pork and
mutton and so forth the terms of
uh for food are in french origin words
whereas those same
animals the pig and the lamb and the cow
those are anglo-saxon words so the
anglo-saxons were the peasants and the
normans french-speaking normans were the
upper class
and with all of these different
linguistic influences
the
spelling in english is very inconsistent
and this is definitely an obstacle in
english it's a delight to go to a
language like spanish like russian
others
where
what you see is what you get in other
words you don't have to guess at how to
pronounce words russian isn't as good as
spanish spanish is
you can just pronounce anything you see
that's far from the case in english we
all know you know
o-u-g-h can be pronounced any number of
different ways
and uh you know for me like studying
greek where they have some of the same
issues or
persian or or arabic where you can't
necessarily tell how a word is
pronounced just by looking at it uh
those kinds of problems exist in english
you could argue that
the fact that english
seems to be more idiomatic but that's
not really true i think there's maybe
there are more tenses than some
languages i think every language has its
grammatical intricacies
and and i don't think those differences
are so important
the big advantage with english is that
there's so much of it around us we don't
have to go looking for content in
english we have it we have movies we
have netflix series we have
uh podcasts on every imaginable subject
and given that the the fastest way to
improving in
any language is to do a lot of listening
and reading to be exposed to the
language and eventually to just start
speaking the language without worrying
then the conditions for english are
better than for any other language
because there is more content there are
more english speakers around whether
native speakers or otherwise that you
are going to meet
wherever you go that you're going to
need when you're in an airport
so that the the need for the language
language is greater the availability of
content the opportunity to use it all of
these things make
learning english easier now this all
does require a certain level of
commitment from the learner
and so
obviously if you're a young hockey
player that arrives from russia as in
the case of vancouver we had a player
called paul kozen podcolson who arrived
not speaking uh english and now he
speaks english i think quite well he's
thrown in with a bunch of guys they
might be swedes finns americans
canadians he's got to speak english and
so therefore thrown into that
environment he's going to end up
speaking
whereas the immigrant typically who
comes to canada or the u.s they have
their support group of people of the
same sort of origin who speak that
language
they
don't go out for dinner with the
teammates every night they sit at home
and watch
the immigrant does tv programs from the
home country
and so
you know to break through in english
english even though the opportunities
are great it does require commitment and
if you're living in say brazil or if
you're living in
japan
then you have to make a commitment to
take advantage of all of the english
content that is out there
and if the opportunities for speaking
don't exist
you have to continue with your
input activities
you know until that opportunity arises
and the opportunity will arise now you
can also find online tutors language
partners language exchange partners you
can travel
but even if those kinds of things aren't
available available to you there is just
so much content available that you can
absorb that you can listen that you can
read you can train your brain you can
get used to it you can feel comf
confident that you understand which is
of course the key skill so that you can
prepare yourself and then when you get
in a situation
where you have to you know use the
language go for it don't worry about it
the world is full of
non-native speakers of english who speak
with a variety of accents who don't
speak perfectly and their goal is simply
to communicate
so
i guess in conclusion even though i hear
a lot of people say english is difficult
or my english is not good
i think people should stop saying that
their english is not good they should
just continue
hopefully finding ways to enjoy the
language spending time with the language
taking advantage of all the
english language content that's
available
opportunities to use english which are
available go for it without any
inhibitions and not really
set
standards for themselves that are
unrealistic
so i hope that was helpful i want to
encourage people who are learning
english
no matter what your level don't
be tough on yourselves and by the same
token
you should continue to try to improve
and how do you continue to improve keep
using the language keep listening keep
reading
thank you for listening bye for now